okay with me now to discuss the latest
developments on the ground in Ukraine as
defense and security analyst air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell thanks for being with
us so uh there's been an attack of
course on kiev for overnight is this
significant as far as what's happening
now in Ukraine well yes we're getting a
series of reports unconfirmed of exactly
what the targeting is at the moment
normally this sort of targeting in the
city would be a prerequisite for some
for book or ground forces Invasion but
as we've seen recently most of the
Russian forces have left the area so it
looks very unlikely that's the case what
looks far more likely is this is
retribution for the loss of the the the
the the the flagship of the Russian
Fleet and um the Ukrainian temerity to
attack Russia away from natural Ukraine
itself
right and as and as far as that attack
on uh the the musk fall uh the Russians
claimed the uh the ship was lost due to
a fire on board of course that's the the
story they want to put out there well
why would this lead to the Strategic
targeting of Kiev the capital no it's a
great it's a great question I mean the
Russians have stuck to their story that
they claim it's been lost to a fire um
I've served several detachments on board
Her Majesty's carriers and uh fire risk
is one of the most important things that
the crews train for every day literally
every day
um and have a fire so serious that it
causes the ship to sing
it is pretty unusual uh particularly the
timing of it so whereas the ukrainians
have claimed that they've shut it down
using two Neptune missiles if we look at
that without getting into the geeky bit
of how the missiles work generally
speaking this missiles fly at a
pre-programmed course then turn on their
radar as they get close to the ship and
they go for the meatiest part of the
ship the biggest cross-section area on
the musk fur that's where all of the
missiles are located so it it would have
that effect it would Target the side of
the ship the missiles would blow up and
of course would cause devastating
consequences so although the Russians
are claiming it's a fire first of all
that seems highly unlikely and secondly
it I do note that the Russian Fleet have
moved further south since that incident
I'm not sure whether the flag stepping
away is slightly less dangerous for
fires As you move South I think the
other reason I think for me is that the
doodle raids in the second world war
were where Japan was Waging War in
America and it's very difficult for
America to take the water to Japan but
if you recall
um the the effort was to Target Japan by
having an outrageous raid of putting an
aircraft carrier quite close and a
one-way mission for people to bomb in
Japan and part of that tactically they
couldn't make much damage do much damage
to Japan but strategically it meant that
the Japanese knew that the war was on
their doorstep and I think what
Ukraine's doing here is very effectively
taking the war outside just to confines
not just waiting for us to attack but
also demonstrating that by taking out
its Flagship and potentially causing
disruption elsewhere its seized in the
initiative which is a really bright
spark and and the Russians taking it
straight back to the capital then yes
unfortunately I think you can just
almost feel the frustration and anger of
Putin that they they've had the temerity
to attack me right I'm going to do some
targeting up there because it does
appear to be strategic targeting there
are specific Targets in the whole of
Ukraine that are uh potentially to do
with missile production or aircraft
production stuff like that and those
targets will have been pre-known to
Russians for years but why they would
choose now to Target them it feels very
much like a a feedback for the temerity
of the Ukrainian forces well it's either
Marshall Sean Bell thanks very much
indeed for now